[Music] Can take one Guinness World Record which
is obviously a massive achievement,
but to take another nine that says something
- you're not goingaway.
And guess what - I'm not going away.
I'm Terry "Turbo" Burrows
- the fastest window cleaner in theworld.
When I found out there was a world record,
I knew I wanted to break it.
I had to work outthe maths, the movements
- the training it's going to need.
I thought, "yeah I can do that. Bring it on!"
When I first started out my Uncle Alfie taught me
how to use the squeegee an applicator
and theywould start wetting up with the right end - with the applicator - and then switch it over and squeegeeingit off
and I thought why not just wet it up
and "ch ch ch ch" - and do that?
Terry had a talent.
And he wondered whereit might take him.
Every day I get up about 7 30.
I come down and make myself some coffees
- probablyabout three or four.
I do a bit of gaming
and then my regime starts.
Welcome to the trainingcamp!
I got myself a window
and fixed it on the back of the garden shed.
And I was practicingaway and what was hilarious about all this
was our neighbor mowing the lawn
and be looking atme thinking
"Why is he cleaning that window
over and over again
but the window don't go throughanywhere
it doesn't see anything - what is he doing?!"
Terry entered his first competition aged 40.
Iremember my first major competition was in France.
It was huge it was like an arena
for the window cleaning competition!
I was absolutely bowled over
and then all of a sudden this person comes upto me
they're carrying the Union Jack for me, I thought
"Oh my God. This is like the Olympics!
Thisis amazing!"
In those eight to nine seconds
you've got to be as fast as you can
you've got fivemoves per window
and wipe the seal clean.
And you've got to keep all that together
just in thosefew seconds - it's nuts.
Terry took home the trophy
and the next one
and the next one.
well actually, he won the next 15 competitions he entered,
and he's not giving up anytime soon.
What you do is youstart from the top here go down like this
and all the time your leg's moved over into position...
anduh -
that is basically it.
Don't look at that bit, you musn't look at that bit. (laughs)
It's my life's passion.
You've got to be tunnel-visioned - which I have been
- and not swayed one iota.
I plan to go out the world
as thefastest window cleaner on the planet.
So if any aliens are up there...
um, that'll becool. You can come down and take me on!
[Music] [Guitar strum]
[Singing] Let me
dip you in me bucket
and give you a squeeze.
Would you let me climb your ladder?
Ooh - you're such a tease!
Let me swing you in me cradle
I'm beggingyou, please!
Let me dip you in me bucket of love!
I see you every day as you walk by
I wonder if you notice me way up in thesky
all the fellas on the site... [Fades]